I've noticed this trend and I I I am
never going to be the one that says
appearance is not important appearance
is definitely important but you get to
see what women value by what they spend
their money and their time on and some
women are so self-centered that they
have spent years looking in the mirror
taking selfies posing for the camera the
only thing that matters to them is
looking good and looks only go so deep
so many times I hear women talk about
femininity and talk about how being
feminine is is about having a certain
look the most feminine women that I have
met were not trendy they were not
fashionable femininity has nothing to
femininity at its core is selflessness
it is serving your man your community
and the people around you that is
femininity it is not this over Obsession
that we have on the latest fashion
trends makeup Beauty and promiscuity and